una ceremonia militar para despedir a
angela merkel para despedir a una
política que como pocos marcó el destino
de alemania y de europa durante los
últimos 16 años
angela merkel dejará el poder con altos
niveles de popularidad llegará
oficialmente de ser la canciller de
alemania el próximo miércoles cuando
asuma su sucesor olaf scholz y de ahí
que los alemanes actualmente estén
discutiendo no solamente lo que pueda
traer esta nueva era política de
alemania sino también lo que deja la
actual el legado de angela merkel la era
de angela merkel al frente de alemania
estuvo para bien o para mal marcada por
las diferentes crisis que debió asumir
la crisis financiera la crisis de la
eurozona la crisis migratoria el break
sheet y más recientemente la lucha
contra la pandemia del coronavirus una
pandemia que sigue afectando al país de
manera muy dramática quienes critican el
legado de angela merkel aseguran con
frecuencia que precisamente por tener
que lidiar con todas esas crisis
ang la mente no pudo presentar una
visión de largo plazo para el país
defienden el legado de angela merke
también explican en ocasiones que en
medio de momentos muy turbulentos angela
merkel pudo entregar estabilidad
estabilidad una palabra que muchos
esperan también sea una prioridad del
nuevo gobierno alemán liderado por olaf
scholz